i love pokemon no i know you love it no
but you you know i love it i had this a
year before i realized that there was a
trading card game before i before i
ventured into it as an adult i love
pokemon why
but it was a card game before it was
yeah but i didn't know i didn't know the
cards were like trading as an asset like
i don't know there's like a marketplace
for the tcg the trade card game yeah
right
i just always on pokemon i played in
high school all the time i just loved it
but why why what was the
ah i did i love pokemon i thought it was
just so creative i love the i love the
characters i love the battle i love the
story i love
i love everything about it i just i
don't know what was the best game though
yeah what's the favorite generation yeah
so the ones i always go back to like
every three years i'll i'll buy a game
boy color okay and i'll buy pokemon red
yeah pokemon uh yellow sometimes like
when pikachu follows you you could take
guitar game or color yeah okay
not i'll never do the game more advanced
oh no you gotta check out like sapphire
so so that was i played when i was
younger yeah but
[ __ ] you guys
anything that goes outside 151 bro i'm
like i don't i just it gets too big
because it's too big man but it almost
doesn't even matter because like the
youth now gave a [ __ ] about pogo why
what can you can you explain to me what
the hell yeah pokemon andrew bro which
one would you think he is
no no but have you ever thought about
what it is
about pokemon that makes you obsessed
with it because you spent [ __ ] money
on this pokemon i have the most
expensive pokemon card in the world oh
which one
the one of one in tempe get your
illusion
what do you know about that card
thank you
you call that the push
he goes oh yeah
[Laughter]
that was amazing
no it's a pikachu is the number one
this is a pikachu i thought it'd be a
charizard
charizards are generally number two i
have one of those as well but i got the
one pikachu dude pikachu is like one of
the most recognizable characters on
earth pokemon's the highest grossing
media franchise in the world really yeah
how much number one 90 plus billion
probably
probably approaching 100.
i went to a bts [ __ ] concert
yeah right you got that this is
something dynamite
damn so you gave up logan gang bruh for
first time
it's low
oh [ __ ]
maverick bro that's fire dude that's
like when non-gang people don't sign